FREE ADVICE.
DO YOURSELF A FAVOR.
GO FISHING.
STOP TALKING.
WITH REACTION, N.R.A., TV
CONTRIBUTOR FORMER SECRET
SERVICE AGENT DAN BONGINO
AUTHOR OF THE BEST-SELLING
BOOK IN BOOKSTORES BOOKSTORES TI
BOOK IN BOOKSTORES BOOKSTORES TS
BOOK IN BOOKSTORES BOOKSTORES TW
BOOK IN BOOKSTORES BOOKSTORES TE
BOOK IN BOOKSTORES BOOKSTORES T,
GERALDO, GERALDO SHOW, FOX
NEWS CORRESPONDENT AT LARGE.
THIS COMES DOWN TO A
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE AS IT
RELATES TO THE PRESIDENT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT CROSSED
THE BORDER, THE WEAK BORDERS
AND RAPED AMERICANS.
NOT THE MAJORITY.
NOBODY IS SAYING THE MAJORITY.
I KNOW MOST PEOPLE WANT JOBS
AND A BETTER OPPORTUNITY.
I DON'T BLAME PEOPLE.
I HAVE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
I HAVE BEEN IN MEXICO.
OTHER PEOPLE LIKE KATE STEINLY
HAS BEEN MURDERED.
ISN'T ONE MURDER, ISN'T ONE
RAPE ENOUGH?
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS OF THE
VIOLENT CRIMES ARE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS,
GERALDO, OVER THE YEARS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, SEAN, WE HAD
A LITTLE EARTHQUAKE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY.
5.3 ON THE RICHTER SCALE.
>> Sean: BECAUSE YOU ARE OUT
THERE.
>> YOUR OPENING MONOLOGUE WAS
TOUGHER THAN THE EARTHQUAKE.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY BEFORE I
START THAT I SHARE YOUR
ENTHUSIASM THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATINGS
HAVE NOW TICKED UP AND INDEED
AT LEAST ONE SURVEY ARE ABOVE
50% FOR THE FIRST TIME DURING
HIS PRESIDENCY.
>> Sean: 51%.
>> BUT I DO BELIEVE, THIS IS
WHERE I KNOW THAT YOU AND I
DISAGREE AND I DISAGREE WITH
MOST OF THE AUDIENCE WATCHING
ME NOW WILL DISAGREE.
I THINK THAT THIS IMMIGRANT
CRISIS IS MANUFACTURED.
I THINK IT'S AN OVERREACTION
TO THE SO-CALLED CARAVAN OF
1,000 THAT IS NOW BROKEN UP IN
THE SOUTHERN CITY AROUND
PUEBLA.
THEY ARE SEEKING ASYLUM.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE SEEN THE
TAPE.
I SAT THROUGH SECURITY
BRIEFING IN SEVEN-YEAR PERIOD
OF TIME INCLUDING MURDER, RAPE
AND OTHER VIOLENT CRIME.
642,000 CRIMES IN TOTAL.
YOU HAVE SEEN ME PLAY THE
TAPE.
HOW CAN YOU STAY IT'S
OVERSTATED?
>> I SAY IT WITH ABSOLUTE
CERTAINTY.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IS NEAR
46-YEAR LOWS.
WE HAD A SPIKE IN MARCH,
PROBABLY HAVING TO DO WITH THE
DEMAND FOR AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS --
>> Sean: LET ME BRING IN
DAN.
IF ONE WOMAN IS RAPED OR
MURDERED ISN'T THAT ENOUGH
THAT WE PROTECT OUR FAMILY,
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS FIRST?
>> IT ABSOLUTELY IS.
I WAS LISTENING TO MARK STEYN
AND HE HAD GREAT COMMENTS.
HE SAID IT'S ODD, IF YOU ARE
AN AMERICAN CITIZEN ENTERING
BACK TO AMERICA IN AN AIRPORT
YOU GET A CAVITY SEARCH AT THE
BORDER BY OUR OWN PEOPLE.
BUT YET THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
CASUALLY WALK ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, NARCO
TRAFFICKERS.
WE KNOW TERRORISTS ARE AWARE
OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
GERALDO AND I HAD A BEEF ABOUT
THIS THE OTHER DAY BUT IT'S
TRUE.
IT'S A FACT.
I KNOW THEY ARE AWARE OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
PEOPLE HAVE DIED.
SEAN, THERE IS A REAL PRICE TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
I DON'T KNOW WHY GERALDO KEEPS
DENYING THAT.
>> Sean: 20 SECONDS,
GERALDO.
>> THAT IS NOT FAIR.
THAT IS NOT FAIR.
I DO NOT DENY THAT THERE IS
CRIME COMMITTED AGAINST THESE